le général de gaulle toujours à pire
poursuit sa promenade d'amitié travers
la france le bois cian ans en passant
par la lorraine comme de la marche dont
il a fait un second hymne national
l'hôtel de ville l'accueil et ils
répondront nouvelle ovation dans une
foule enthousiaste de masser sur la
place stanislas ou des merveilles de la
france
a lille maintenant sa ville natale le
général de gaulle apporte le salut du
plus illustre de ses fils est d'abord se
recueille devant le monument aux morts
la pluie n'a pas été un enthousiasme des
lillois aquitaine bravement sous
l'averse
mais la pluie fait aussi partie du décor
et était bon que le chef du gouvernement
parcouru l'un après l'autre tous les
climats du pays de france a clamé sous
le crachin du nord comme il l'a été sous
le soleil du midi